نعلم جميعًا أن الحياة يمكن أن تسقطنا ،
لكن في أمريكا لم نبقى أبدًا ،
فالأمريكيون دائمًا ما يستيقظون
اليوم وهذا ما نفعله ، أمريكا
تنهض من جديد
تختار الأمل على الخوف على الحقيقة على
الأكاذيب والنور على الظلام
بعد 100 يوم من الإنقاذ والتجديد
أمريكا جاهزة للإقلاع من وجهة نظري ،
نحن نعمل مرة أخرى ، نحلم مرة أخرى
بالاكتشاف مرة أخرى وقيادة العالم
مرة أخرى
، أظهرنا لبعضنا البعض والعالم
أنه لا يوجد
أي توقف في أمريكا
منذ 100 يوم كان منزل أمريكا يحترق ،
كان علينا أن نتصرف  وشكرًا
للقيادة غير العادية
لرئيس البرلمان بيلوسي زعيم الأغلبية شومر
والدعم الساحق من
الشعب الأمريكي الديمقراطيين
والمستقلين والجمهوريين ،
لقد عملنا معًا ، لقد مررنا
خطة الإنقاذ الأمريكية
وهي واحدة من أكثر حزم الإنقاذ ذات
الأهمية في التاريخ الأمريكي
التي نشهدها بالفعل.
لقد رأينا النتائج بالفعل
بعد أن وعدت أننا سنحصل على 100 مليون
طلقة لقاح covet 19
في أذرع الناس في غضون مائة يوم
سنكون قد قدمنا أكثر من 220 مليون لق
ة مرغوبة في
لك الأيام المائة بفضل كل
لمساعدة منكم جميعًا